I built my dream career full of so many  possibilities based on my passion for  motion design and by learning how to  create high level motion design that  keeps clients coming back again and  again but did you know that I'm actually  self-taught I've had no formal training  and I actually started teaching myself  motion design back in the early 2000s in  fact over 20 years ago reality for me  was a lot different in fact I was  working at a factory trying to support  my family and struggling to make ends  meet every single day in 2004 when I  decided to really Embrace motion design  and take my life and career in another  Direction I was literally living at the  poverty level I had no idea what I was  doing I had no one to talk to I was  scared out of my mind and it was a long  and lonely grind fast forward to today  and I have mad skills and can  essentially create anything that I see  in my creative mind and that my friends  is power as a motion designer